تتحول الان الى مقر اداره الطوارئ
والكوارث في انقره معنا من هناك فرح
الزمان شوقي فرح زمان الكثير من التصريحات
التركيه عبر الوزراء وزير الصحه وزير
الدفاع كذلك وزير الطاقه كيف تتعامل
السلطات مع هذه الكارثه
وتوابعها
وعدد ضحاياها الضخم حتى الان
في هذه الاثناء وفي الغرفه المجاوره من
حيث اقف يعقد الان مؤتمرا صحفيا جديدا
تعلن في اداره الكوارث عن والطوارئ عن
التطورات المرتبطه بعدد القتلى والجرحى
والى حين حصولي على تلك الارقام اخر
التطورات هي اعلان السلطات في تركيا
الحداد العام لمده اسبوع تنكيس الاعلام في
كافه المؤسسات التركيه وفي كافه المقر
الدبلوماسيه خارج البلاد المؤتمر الصحفي
الاخير الذي سبق الذي يعقد في هذه الاثناء
في اداره هيئه الطوارئ والكوارث كان
مؤتمرا مشتركا لعدد من الوزراء الذين
ذهبوا لتفقد الاوضاع فيها تاي وهي واحده
من المدن التي وصفت بالمدن المنكوبه وزير
الدفاع مع وزير الطاقه والموارد الطبيعيه
مع وزير الزراعه مع وزير الصحه كلهم
تواجدوا هناك وقدموا تقارير عن اخر
الارقام وزير الصحه قال في حينه القتلى
تجاوز الالف وستمائه وخمسين قتيلا الجرحى
اصبح احد عشر الفا واكد وجود صعوبات في
عمليات الانقاذ واغاثه المنكوبين ليس فقط
بسبب سوء الاحوال الجويه وانما بسبب تكرار
الهزات الارتداديه وتحدث عن عشره مدن فيها
اضرار بالغه على حد وصفه وزير الدفاع من
جهته
ركز على اعمال الانقاذ على طواقم الانقاذ
العسكريه واكدى بان وزاره الدفاع التركيه
قامت بانشاء جسر جوي امن ممرا عبر 17
طائره تقوم بنقل المساعدات الى المناطق
المتضرره ويقول ان الجيش في هذه الاثناء
يعمل على توفير اماكن لايواء المتضررين
لاسيام مع حلول ساعات الليل وتراجع انخفاض
درجات الحراره وزير الطاقه من جهته يؤكد
حصول اضرار في شبكات الكهرباء والغاز وذلك
بعد الاعلان عن قطعها بحسب اجراءات
احترازيه تتخذها اداره الكوارث والطوارئ
لكن الحديث الان يدور عن تضرر في البناء
التحتيه من قبل شبكات الكهرباء والغاز
هناك بعض خطوط الغاز التي تعرضت لحرائق
وتتعامل السلطات الان مع ما هو ابعد من
مساله اخراج
المتضررين من تحت الانقاد كذلك تصريحات
اخرى تتحدث عن صعوبات في هبوط الطائرات في
مطار
انطاكيا والذي تعرض كذلك لاضرار ازاء
الزلزال الذي بلغت شدته 7.7 على مقياس
ريختر الان الرئاسه التركيه تتحدث عن
ضروره اجلاء المدنيين وهناك عدد من
الاشخاص الذين بداوا
بالتوافد الى مدن ثانيه اما عن طريق الجو
او عن طريق
البر وهناك صفحات على مواقع التواصل
الاجتماعي
تنشر خرائط لطرقات بديله يمكن التنقل
عبرها لاشيما مع وجود انهيارات للصخور على
تلك الطرقات جراءه
الزلزال والذي استمر لفتره ليست بالوجيزه
بطبيعه الحال مره حتى الان ما يقارب 17
ساعه على الزلزال الاشد
وكلما مر الوقت كلما تظالت الفرص باخراج
الاحياء لكن هناك نقطه هامه وهي المناطق
النائيه الحديثه يدور الان عن مدن الكبرى
ويدور الحديث عن ضروره ايصال فرق الانقاذ
والطواقم الى المناطق الابعد الارياف
المناطق النائيه
تحتاج كذلك الى المساعدات وتحتاج الى جهود
حثيثه لاخراج المتضررين فنحن شاهدنا نعم
فنمكن وصفها بالمهوله وبالمرعبه في المدن
الكبرى ابنيه كبيره فماذا هذه هي والارياف
نعم